So I guess what I wanted to talk to you about,
what's a few things?
First of all,
I know that your book is coming out in January and I've preordered it.
I'm very excited about that.
So you are going on a book tour that's,
yeah,
just talking to the book is going to be published by penguin counted down also
in the UK,
which I'm really excited about because penguin is a top rate publisher.
We were just having a marketing discussion today.
I'm going to England in,
in the middle of January as well as to Amsterdam and uh,
we talked about,
so there's two,
I'm doing two talks in the UK,
in London,
both of which I think have sold out now.
Yeah,
three I checked this morning.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
So the thousand seat venue sold out in about one day,
which is hard to fathom.
And then I talked to them about renting a bus,
having it painted in some,
um,
mean like way I suppose I probably not like,
I hope nothing close to what Milo is doing now.
Who knows?
Then I thought I'd run a contest for the bus design.
Yeah.
And so they are,
they seem like that.
They seem to think that was a good idea.
And I think I want to do the same thing in the u s so that should be
ridiculously entertaining and surreal.
Bus Tours start.
Would it be next summer or next fall?
Well,
yeah,
probably next fall in the u s and maybe,
I don't know where it went in the UK,
maybe in the spring,
but sometime next year and I'm going to Australia,
New Zealand and I'm sure I'll,
by the looks of things I'll be going all over the place.
And so that's also extremely interesting and somewhat unexpected.
So,
so 2018 looks like it's going to be a very adventurous and exciting year for
you.
Yeah.
You mean like compare it as contrasted to 2017 say,
well 2017 the latter part was I think been really good.
Like I've attended all your lectures.
Uh,
the psychological significance of the biblical stories they've been sold out and
uh,
I,
that's a crazy thing.
The question and answer period.
At the end has been so sophisticated,
really in depth questions and the audiences really tuned in and very,
very mature and there's so much respect and silence during the entire lecture.
I'm sure you're very pleased,
but uh,
it's amazing.
Yeah,
I'm reading
pleased about it and I've learned a tremendous amount.
I mean,
part of the reason I,
I've wanted to do a series on the psychological significance of the biblical
stories for long time,
15 years probably,
and never had the opportunity,
never set itself up properly.
And I've,
I've learned a ridiculous about doing it and I'm really looking forward to
starting it up again.
I'm going to try to do it to go through exodus next year.
Um,
I really liked the exodus exists stories and I know them better than I did the
Abrahamic stories,
for example,
I had to do a lot of,
but that's okay.
It's often,
it's a funny thing when you're lecturing.
Sometimes it's,
I mean,
you need to have a fairly wide background of knowledge,
say that you can draw from,
but in,
in,
in a more specific way.
Sometimes it's not bad to be just one step ahead of the audience and be learning
along with them because it keeps the material really fresh.
So yeah,
that's been,
that's been an amazing thing.
I don't know how many people have watched those biblical lectures now,
but I think it's something upwards of 5 million.
Yeah,
that's,
that's remarkable.
And you know,
what's even more remarkable to me is when I attend is the number of young people
in the audience.
And you know,
that's been really encouraging because I think statistically if we look at
across the board,
um,
I know that young people show not a very strong interest in religion or
religious stories.
Yep.
Don't attend church.
And that's especially true for young men.
And I know it's really funny because I'm talking to young men about religion and
responsibility and there there's a huge market for it,
which is
amazing.
Excuse me,
teasing on unpredictable,
right.
A part of me is not surprised because as you know,
I've spent the last like 22 years kind of in various types of social services
from child protection to young offenders.
And the one thing I noticed is I almost saw that people were like starving for
some type of structure and morality and some type of,
um,
just sort of,
you know,
way to live their lives in a very meaningful way.
And that hunger was very apparent to me.
I didn't realize it was that strong until actually you came along and I saw the
response to you worldwide has been phenomenal.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
it was something,
I was talking to the,
I call them the penguin people because that's actually quite funny,
but I was talking to the penguin people today.
They would ask me how I can account for what's happened over the last year,
say,
and I,
my sense essentially is that young people haven't been talked intelligently to
about responsibility and tradition since like 1965 and that's three generations.
It's way too long.
And so they are starving for it because we've missed half the story.
You know,
people,
they've been fed a diet of nothing but sugar freedom and impulsive pleasure and,
and uh,
and cynicism about,
about structure and tradition.
And you just can't live like that because freedom and novelty and the unexpected
is half the story.
But structure and predictability and responsibilities,
the other half and you,
you have to have both.
Both halves of the story told
no,
your detractors are saying that 90% of your audience is male and most of them
are white male.
I really don't understand why that's an issue.
I also don't think it's,
it's funny.
Um,
you know,
I was going through my Twitter followers yesterday because I,
I'm sending some of them books and I used a program that helped me identify the
most,
sort of a combination of my most influential Twitter followers and also those
who are most likely to be engaged with my material.
And so I identified about 200 of them and you know,
there were some pretty right wing types in there.
Uh,
three or four of them pretty right wing.
Um,
but you know,
three of them were a transsexual porn stars.
Really,
really interesting because you know,
if you looked at the three kind of radical right wingers,
you'd say,
well,
Dr. Peterson attracts radical right wing and followers.
But then,
well,
okay,
what you're going to say about the transsexual porn stars,
literally there were three of them thought,
well,
what do I,
what am I like tarred with the,
with the association transsexual Porn Stars because that seems to be just as as
big a group.
So it's just,
I think Serena,
part of what it is is that if you stand up against the radical left,
let's say,
then it isn't obvious where you're positioned on the political spectrum because
everybody to the right of the radical left is going to agree with you and
that'll include people on the radical,
right.
Correct.
And then people say,
Oh,
well look,
you've got people on the radical right supporting you.
You must be radical.
Right?
And it's a reasonable question,
but,
but it's generally not posed in a reasonable way.
And you know,
you obviously you were out the free speech rally.
I mean the,
there was no evidence whatsoever that the crowd we attracted was anything other
than pretty damn stable center of the road citizens.
And you know,
the other thing about,
about someone's audiences that to assume that I'm mostly appealing to people say
who are right wing.
You'd have to show that the number of people that I'm attracting who are right
wing is somehow bigger than it is in the normal population.
And I,
that's not self evident to me.
And so,
and,
and well,
I mean,
just to some degree,
I think it's beside the point because a lot of what's happening is that the
people who really misunderstand what I'm talking about purposefully or
accidentally or maliciously are looking for any means whatsoever to discredit
me.
And,
uh,
fortunately that has not worked at all.
Yeah.
Not working in the least.